من فرنسا التي شهدت يوما عاشرا من
التظاهرات ضد اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي
تقابله معارضه شعبيه كبيره حيث وصلت اعداد
المحتجين في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس الى
740 الف متظاهر وفقا طبعا الشرطه الفرنسيه
وفي تعزيزات غير مسبوقه اعلنت وزاره
الداخليه انها نشرات 13 الف شرطي بينهم
5500 في باريس وحدها وشهدت الاحتجاجات
اشتباكات بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين في باريس
فيما احرق المتظاهرون مصرفا في مدينه نات
ما ادى الى مواجهات عنيفه مع الشرطه وكانت
نقابات عماليه قد طالت الرئيس الفرنسي
امعني بوقف خططه الراميه الى رفع سن
التقاعد ولكن الحكومه رفضت هذه المطالب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد يرفع الحد
الادنى لسن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
يفقد بعض العاملين في القطاع العام
امتيازاتهم
يرفع عدد سنوات العمل المطلوبه للتاهل
لمعاش تقاعديا كامل لماذا يهتم الفرنسيون
كثيرا بقانون التقاعد ينظر اليه كحجر
الزاويه لنموذج الحمايه الاجتماعيه
يدفع العاملون رسوم الرواتب لتمويل معاشات
المتقاعدين
يحصل جميع العمال الفرنسيين على معاش
تقاعديه
تعد فرنسا من الدول الاوروبيه التي تعتمد
ادنى سنا للتقاعد
حاول كافه الرؤساء المتعاقبين اجراء
تغييرات على قوانين التقاعد
غالبا تشعل غضب الشارع وتنعكس سلبا في
صناديق الاقتراع
لنقل الصوره من فرنسا ينضم الينا من باريس
حسين قنيبر مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا
وينضم الينا ايضا من باريس فادي داهوك
مراسل العربيه سابدا معك باليوم العاشر
للتظاهرات والاحتجاجات على التي عمت
الشوارع الفرنسيه كيف هي الصوره من هناك
نعم ليال ما زال عدد كبير من المتظاهرين
هنا في ساحه لاناسيون الامه متواجدين
وهناك مناوشات تحدث مع الشرطه كما ترون
على الشاشه هناك استخدام للغاز المسيل
للدموع بالاضافه الى ان هناك بعض الحرائق
التي يشعلها المتظاهرون هناك حشد امني
كثيف حقيقه الان يحاولون تفريق ما تبقى من
المتظاهرين هذه التظاهرات التي جمعت
450,000 بحسب النقابات فقط في العاصمه
باريس او في العاصمه وحدها لكن النقابات
تتحدث عن حواله او عن اكثر من مليونير
متظاهر في عموم فرنسا طبعا قبل قليل ايضا
انتهى اجتماع للنقبات وفي مؤتمر صحفي
اعلنوا ان التحرك المقبل سوف يكون في
السادس من شهر ابريل المقبل سيكون ايضا
يوما للتظاهر
والاضراب هناك الان حاله من الفوضى هنا في
هذه الساحه هناك عناصر متجمعه من الشرطه
باعداد كبيره تطلق الغاز المسيل للدموع
كما ترون عبر المتظاهرين الذين يحاولون
ابعاد هذه القنابل وقذفها باتجاه عناصر
الشرطه وايضا يستخدمون الحجاره
نحاول الابتعاد قليلا
عن الغاز
فادي ابقي لنا الصوره مفتوحه لو سمحت
سانتقل الى الزميل حسين قنيبر حسين يعني
توصيف خطوره ما يحصل في فرنسا اليوم بعد
اوصات ماكرونز ذهبت الى اعتبار ان ما يحصل
شبيه بعماي
19588 الى اي مدى اليوم فرنسا يعني امام
مرحله مفصليه
ربما المناسب ليال مساء الخير اولا ان
نقارن ما يحصل اليوم بما حصل في الولايه
الاولى للرئيس الفرنسي الاسبق جاك شيراك
الرئيس الراحل خصوصا في عهد حكومته الاولى
التي تراسها
حينها عام 95
سجلت في فرنسا تظاهرات شارك فيها الملايين
تشبه تلك التي تحصل منذ مطلع هذا العام
والتي كان محورها الاعتراض على اصلاح
النظام التقاعد ما يحصل اليوم اخطر ما فيه
انه لا يلوح في الافق اي مخرج من هذه
الازمه فالحكومه اذا تراجعت وطبعا من
خلفها الرئيس ماكرون اذا تراجع
سيبدوان الضعيفين وسيبدوان كانهما تراجعات
تحت ضغط الشارع واذا لم يتراجع فان الازمه
ستصبح مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات ومن بينها
المزيد من العنف في الشارع يعول على امرين
اما الوساطه التي اقترحت النقابات ان تقوم
بها جهه ما بينها اي بين النقبات والحكومه
وهو ما لم تتحمس له الحكومه التي قال
الناطق باسمها انه لا توجد حاجه الى وسيط
بين النقابات والحكومه بل بامكان الجهتين
ان يتحاورا مباشره ولكن هذا لا يبدو وشيكا
الليالي لان رئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث التي
قالت امس بعد اجتماع في قصر الاليزا
برئاسه ماكرون انها مستعده للتهدئه مع
النقبات وستستقبل قاده احزاب المعارضه
مطلع الشهر المقبل عادت بورن وقالت اليوم
بعد تصريحات نقابيه دعت الى الوساطه بين
النقابات والحكومه قالت بورن ان الحكومه
لا يمكنها ان تعلق تطبيق اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي سيبدا تنفيذه في سبتمبر
المقبل لا تراجع حكوميا حتى الان ويعول
على راي المجلس الدستوري الذي سيعطي رايه
في قانون رفع ست التقاعد خلال ثلاثه
اسابيع احسن اسمح لي ان اعود الى الزميل
فادي على ما يبدو ان المواجهات يعني
احتدمت هناك بين المتظاهرين والشرطه فاديه
هل مازلت تسمعنا
نعم
نعم اسمعك الان المواجهات ما زالت مستمره
الغاز المسيل الدموع ما زال ايضا يطلق من
قبل عناصر الشرطه تطلقه بكثافه لتفريق
المحتجين هنا في هذه الساحه في ساحه
لاناسيو المتظاهرون الذين بقيوا هنا حتى
الان هم من شريحه الشبان في اغلبهم وهم ما
زالوا يقفون في هذه الساحه يرفضون
المغادره طبعا طلبت الشرطه او فتحت بعض
الممرات لمن يريد المغادره وبالفعل غادر
عدد من المتظاهرين لكن هؤلاء ما زالوا
هناك كما ترون هم يرفضون الخروج من هذه
الساحه برغم قيام الشرطه باستخدام الغاز
المسيل للدموع طبعا خلال هذه التظاهرات
كان من المتوقع ان تبدا الاشتراكات في مثل
هذه الساعه او على الاقل في نهايه
التظاهره كان هناك ايضا تحذيرات من قبل
وزير الداخليه جيرالدرمانا من وجود عناصر
من اليسار المتطرف وبعض هؤلاء قال انهم
قدموا من خارج فرنسا راينا بعض هؤلاء خلال
التظاهره وقاموا بالاعتداء على عدد من
المصورين والصحفيين الذين كانوا يغطون هذه
الاحتجاجات قاموا بتحطيم كاميرات كاميرا
لمراسل شبكه سي ان ان على الاقل شبكه سي
ان الامريكيه عندما كان يصور ورفض ان ينزل
الكاميرا او ربما لم يسمعهم هؤلاء يرفضون
طبعا ان يتم تصويرهم حتى لا يتم رصدهم من
قبل قوات الشرطه هو القاء القبض عليهم
لاحقا الان تعود الاشتباكات كما ترون
المتظاهرون يرشقون قوات الشرطه بالحجاره
وبالزجاجات الشرطه تحاول الان تجميع
صفوفها وقد تشن هجوما على هؤلاء
المتضاهنين الذين ترونهم على الشاشه
ويرشقون قوات الشرطه بالحجاره
على كل اليك حسين حسين يعني المعلوم اليوم
ان الفرنسيين يرفضون الماس بنظام التقاعد
الذي يعتبر حجر الزاويه لنموذج الحمايه
الاجتماعيه هناك ما المقبول يعني بالشارع
اليوم خصوصا ان هناك دوافع اقتصاديه كبيره
امام هذا القرار
نعم في الواقع الحكومه والرئيس يدافعان عن
اصرارهما على تنفيذ قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد ورفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما من
خلال القول ان النظام التقاعد يعاني من
عجز سيبلغ عام 203020 مليار يورو ولا سبيل
في ضوء ارتفاع معدل اعمار الفرنسيين
المتوسط لاعمار الفرنسيين ارتفع خلال
العقود الاخيره ولا سبيل الى الاستمرار في
دفع التقاعد لهذه الاجيال التي تشيخ في
فرنسا الا من خلال عمل الفرنسيين عامين
اضافيين اما المعترضون على هذا القرار من
جانب الحكومه فيقولون ان بامكانها ان تحصل
اموالا من جوانب اخرى وان توفر في امكنه
اخرى بدل ان تعمد الى فرض هذا الرفع لسن
التقاعد في كل الاحوال المخرج اليوم يبدو
صعبا معقدا من خلال التصعيد الكلامي
المتبادل بين الحكومه والرئيس من جهه
والاحزاب احزاب اليسار والنقابات من جهه
اخرى لا يبدو ان في الافقي حلولا كثيره
اشاره ما دمت تحدثت عن الجانب الاقتصادي
لان خسائر القطاع السياحي والفندقي خلال
اسبوع واحد في باريس بلغت نسبتها ما بين
20 الى 30% تراجعا بالمقارنه مع الحركه
الاعتياديه فيما تراجعت نسبه الاقبال على
السياحه والفنادق في مدن اخرى كمدينه تران
في الغرب بنسبه 60% خلال اسبوع واحد وفي
برضه بنسبه 30% تراجعت الحركه السياحيه
والفندقيه وفي تولوز بنسبه 29 وهذا يعلمه
المتظاهرين بشكل فرنسيين يعني النقبات
والمتطرد البدايه يعلمون بان هذه التحركات
ستشل الاقتصاد الفرنسي ولكن بالنسبه لهم
طبعا الموضوع يعني الضغط على الحكومه هو
اهم بكثير من اي شيء اخر شكرا لكما مدير
مكتب العربيه في باريس حسين قنيبر وايضا
فادي الداهوك مراسل العربيه من باريس